>>> DESPITE THE STORIES OF
REFUGEES MAKING IT TO EUROPE, A
QUARTER OF THEM ARE IN CAMPS.
THE LARGEST ARE IN KENYA.
THESE CAMPS HOME TO A HALF
MILLION REFUGEES FLEEING
VIOLENCE AND CONFLICT FOR THREE
DECADES.
ALL OF THAT COULD CHANGE.
THE KENYAN GOVERNMENT WANTS THEM
TO SHUT THEM DOWN, A MOVE THAT
SPARKED OUTRAGE.
SOME OF THE REFUGEES WERE BORN
IN THE CAMPS, MANY HAVE NOT
KNOWN LIFE ANYWHERE ELSE.
KENYA'S HIGH COURT PUT A
TEMPORARY HALT ON THE PLAN, BUT
FATE OF THE TWO CAMPS IS
UNCERTAIN.
PART OF WHAT'S AT STAKE IS THAT
KENYA HAS HAD A DIPLOMATIC SPAT,
APPEARS TO BE BEING RESOLVED,
THEY THREATENED TO CLOSE DOWN
CAMPS SEVERAL TIMES.
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS TIME THAT
SEEMS DIFFERENT.
>> WE HAVE HEARD THIS IN THE
PAST, SEVERAL TIMES THE PAST FEW
YEARS, KENYAN GOVERNMENT SAID IT
WANTS TO CLOSE DOWN THE REFUGEE
CAMPS.
THESE SPRAWLING CAMPS THAT HOUSE
MORE THAN 400,000 PEOPLE, MOSTLY
FROM SOMALIA AND SOUTH SUDAN.
WE HEARD IT BEFORE, IN 2016
FOLLOWING TERROR ATTACKS IN
KENYA, THE GOVERNMENT SAID IT IS
A SOURCE OF INSECURITY, THEY
WANTED TO CLOSE IT DOWN.
WE SAW THIS FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
BEING OFFERED TO REFUGEES.
BUT THIS TIME THEY'RE
QUESTIONING HOW SERIOUS THE
THREAT IS OF CLOSING THE CAMPS,
SOME WOULD SAY THE TIMING DURING
A POLITICAL CRISIS GOING ON
BETWEEN SOMALIA AND KENYA,
HEIGHTENED TENSION, IS THIS JUST
POLITICS.
YOU HAVE THE UNITED NATIONS
SAYING LET'S WORK OUT A
SOLUTION, SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION
FOR THE CAMPS.
THE KENYAN GOVERNMENT SET A
DATE, JUNE 30th, NEXT YEAR.
THOSE CAMPS WILL BE SHUTDOWN.
THEY SEEM TO BE DETERMINED THIS
TIME.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO THE
CAMP'S RESIDENTS, THE KENYAN
GOVERNMENT SAY SOME OFFERED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCIDENT GREAT
INTO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY THROUGH
WORK PERMITS AND THAT OTHERS
WILL BE SENT BACK TO THEIR
COUNTRIES OF ORIGIN, AND THAT IS
A TERRIFYING PROPOSAL, ZAIN, FOR
PEOPLE AS YOU MENTIONED, MANY OF
THEM, TENS OF THOUSANDS, THAT
KNOW NO OTHER HOME THAN THESE
CAMPS.
GENERATIONS LIVING THERE FOR
DECADES, WHO FLED INSECURITY,
INSTABILITY, AND COUNTRIES OF
ORIGIN, THAT'S STILL THE PLACES
LIKE SOMALIA WHERE THEY CAN'T
RETURN.
LISTEN TO WHAT SOME RESIDENTS
TOLD CNN EARLIER.
>> IT HAS SHOCKED ME BECAUSE NOT
ONLY -- THIS IS THE ONLY HOME I
HAVE, ONLY FLAG I SEE IS FLAG OF
UNITY.
>> WE HAVE NO PLACE IN SOMALIA.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
MY CHILDREN ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH IT, AND IT IS NOT SAFE AT
ALL.
>> Reporter: ZAIN, THAT MAN HAS
BEEN AT THE CAMP 30 YEARS.
HIS CHILDREN HAVE KNOWN NO OTHER
HOME.
IN ADDITION TO THIS LIFE IN
LIMBO IN CAMPS, PEOPLE ARE
FACING THIS ANXIETY AND
UNCERTAINTY.
YET AGAIN, A ROLLER COASTER,
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TO THEM.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE THE PERFECT GUEST.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF HER BEFORE,
SHE WAS BORN IN A REFUGEE CAMP
AFTER HER FAMILY FLED CIVIL WAR
IN SOMALIA, LIVED THERE SEVEN
YEARS.
HERE IS AFTER SHE MOVED TO THE
UNITED STATES.
SHE'S A TOP MODEL GRACING VOGUE
AND OTHERS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
YOU WERE BORN IN THE REFUGEE
CAMP.
CAN I SAY, YOU HAD QUITE A LIFE,
BY THE WAY.
YOU WERE BORN THERE, AND IT WAS
YOUR HOME, PART OF YOUR
IDENTITY, YOUR CULTURE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
CAMP POTENTIALLY CLOSING?
>> YOU KNOW, KIND OF LIKE THE
REFUGEES SAID THEMSELVES,
SHOCKED.
WHEN I HEARD NEWS THEY WERE
GOING TO CLOSE THE CAMPS, I WAS
SHOCKED.
THERE ARE REFUGEES THAT LIVED
THERE SINCE BEGINNING OF THE
CAMP.
AMAZING THAT KENYA WAS ABLE TO
HOST REFUGEES FOR NEARLY THREE
DECADES, AND I'M SAD TO SEE IT
CLOSING.
>> WALK US THROUGH WHAT IT WAS
LIKE GROWING UP THERE.
PEOPLE MAY HAVE STEREOTYPICAL
VIEWS OF WHAT IT IS LIKE AT A
REFUGEE CAMP, WHAT IT IS LIKE TO
LIVE AT A REFUGEE CAMP.
IT IS LIKE A CITY.
THERE'S A LOAN SYSTEM,
BUSINESSES, TRADE.
BUT ABOVE ALL, THERE'S A REAL
SENSE OF COMMUNITY.
EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS LIKE THERE.
>> YES.
I MEAN, I ALWAYS SAY MY
CHILDHOOD WAS MADE, ALTHOUGH WE
HAD BOUTS OF MALARIA AND FOOD
INSECURITY, THERE'S NO COMMUNITY
LIKE IT.
IT IS 66% WOMEN AND CHILDREN, SO
WE ARE TALKING A NEWER TURING
ENVIRONMENT.
IT HOUSES REFUGEES FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD, ALL OVER AFRICA.
SO IT IS AMAZING KENYA WAS ABLE
TO HOST US FOR SO LONG, AND I
FEEL LIKE THERE SHOULD BE SOME
SORT OF INTEGRATION SYSTEM SO
THE REFUGEES CAN STAY.
A LOT OF THEM WERE LIKE MYSELF,
SOMEONE WHO WAS BORN THERE, ALL
THEY KNOW, AND SO IT OPERATES
LIKE ITS OWN MODERN DAY CITY.
THEY HAVE VERY INFORMAL ECONOMY,
DO BUSINESS LOANS, AND THE
REFUGEES MADE IT HOME.
AND THEY'RE THRIVING, A LOT OF
THEM ARE.
>> OUR CHILDHOOD FORMS A HUGE
PART OF WHO WE ARE, WHAT WE END
UP BECOMING.
HOW DO YOU THINK YOUR TIME IN
KAKUMA MAY HAVE PREPARED YOU OR
SET YOU UP FOR THE LIFE YOU LEAD
TODAY?
>> IT MADE ME A DIPLOMATIC
CITIZEN.
EARLY ON IN LIFE, I FACED SOME
OF THE GREATEST ISSUES.
KAKUMA TAUGHT ME SO MANY
VALUABLE LESSONS.
REFUGEES THAT FLED WAR, FAMILIAR
IN, FOOD INSECURITY, SO MANY
DIFFERENT REASONS.
WE FOUND OURSELVES IN KAKUMA,
AND EARLY ON JUST GAVE ME THIS
GREAT SENSE OF APPRECIATING
OTHERS, FINDING STRENGTH IN
COMMUNITY.
WE WERE ALL THAT WE HAD.
>> SO JUST IN TERMS OF KENYATA'S
DECISION TO CLOSE THIS CAMP, ON
ONE HAND, PRESIDENT OF KENYA
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE FEARS THAT THE CAMPS COULD
BE A BREEDING GROUND FOR AL
SHABAAB.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MORE TO DO WITH
DIPLOMATIC SPAT BETWEEN KENYA
AND SOMALIA.
IF YOU COULD HAVE TEN MINUTES OF
THE PRESIDENT'S TIME, MAYBE HE
IS WATCHING THE PROGRAM NOW,
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> I WOULD SAY CONVERSATIONS
SHOULDN'T BE HAD ABOUT CLOSING
THE CAMP WITHOUT REFUGEES
THEMSELVES.
THIS IS THEIR FUTURE THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, THEIR CHILDREN'S
LIFE IN LIMBO CURRENTLY.
I WOULD AGAIN SAY FIRST, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT, FOR
HOUSING REFUGEES, FOR PROVIDING
A SAFE PLACE IN TIME OF
UNCERTAINTY FOR SO MANY
THOUSANDS OF REFUGEES, AND
BETWEEN THOSE, TALKING NEARLY
HALF A MILLION REFUGEES.
SO I WOULD JUST AGAIN GREATLY
ASK FOR A WAY TO INTEGRATE THE
REFUGEES INTO KENYA, OPPOSED TO
SENDING THEM HOME.
A LOT OF THEM FLED THEIR NATIVE
COUNTRY.
IF IT WAS SAFE, THEY WOULD HAVE
STAYED, BUT THEY DIDN'T.
>> THERE ARE HUGE QUESTIONS NOW
AS TO WHAT HAPPENS TO THESE
REFUGEES, WHERE THEY END UP
GOING, ESPECIALLY ONES BORN IN
KENYA WHO KNO